allez on est mardi soir en est dans le
hall 3 dans l'espace réservé à la
bourgogne franche comté vous le voyez à
c'est très calme et exposants ne sont
pas là en fait l'action ce soir elle se
passe là bas c'est la soirée spéciale
bourgogne franche comté c'est un
événement assez politique il y à
marie-guite dufay la présidente de la
région n'a aussi vu julien odoul mais il
ya aussi des personnes des exposants qui
proposent à déguster des spécialités de
la région et moi à vous l'entendez
peut-être ai-je un accent je suis
marseillais et j'avoue que je ne connais
absolument pas les spécialités de la
bourgogne et la franche-comté je me suis
dit c'était l'occasion ce soir de les
découvrir on va faire ça je vous emmène
allez
allez première étape de ce voyage
culinaire initiatique ans va découvrir
la saucisse de morteau avec
jean-françois il en train de découper en
le voyant soir jean françois halin ce
que tu déjà vous pouvez m'expliquer ce
que c'est là c'est la saucisse elle
vient d'où c'est quoi ces de la saucisse
de morteau là et là de la saucisse de
montbéliard c'est quoi la différence la
taille
c'est la plus grosse
le grain est plus gros ici la mm à 6 mm
et celle là où elle à une cheville
reconnaissables par la cheville et
l'autre c'est du boyau pareil de pauvres
et les plus petites est haché plus fin
l'assaisonnement est ce qu'il ya une
différence au bout c'est quoi la
différence un petit peu plus de cumin
dans cela après chaque fabricant à sa
petite recette mais qui est toujours
régi par le cahier des charges va parce
qu'on veut vous vous êtes où vous êtes
installés ou dans votre région nous on
est à la franche comté la zone de
production va de dole
dole luxeuil
montbéliard et la frontière suisse on
peut goûter sur la conseillère
donc ça c'est la morteau morteau merci
bombay le très bon c'est pas très poli
je mange je parle en mon jean
monsieur validé
et donc celle là c'est là on va la
goutte est aussi
très bonne aussi
trente producteurs
moi j'ai une petite préférence pour
salah quand même vous avez une
préférez-vous salah oui chacun sait où
moi j'aime bien les deux ponts mercier
jean françois
allez on va maintenant avec loïc pour se
désaltérer un petit peu donc on est sur
une bière qui franc comtoise ici vous
êtes à besançon c'est ça tout à fait on
est la brasserie les deux fûts à
besançon avec une bière 100 % franc
comtoise qu'est ce que vous pouvez me
proposer comme dr là alors notre bière
blonde qui est faite avec du malt d'orge
franc comtois bio à 100% et du houblon
alsacien allez ça donne envie je veux
bien donc de la blonde on va goûter ça
vous avez quoi d'autre comme bière sinon
dans votre dans votre structure alors
dans la gamme de la brasserie les deux
flux on propose une bière blonde une
bière ambrée de la blanche de la bière
noire avec des mâles torréfié sur des
arômes de café et une berraj pied est ce
qu'il ya une spécificité la bière franc
comtoise alors oui aujourd'hui une biais
il ya une spécificité c'est la filière
de céréales franc comtois
depuis quatre ans maintenant on
travaille avec de l'orge franc comtois
c'est les céréales sont produits dans le
val de saône grosso modo entre gré vers
la paix n ° et on travaille avec des
céréales 100% franc comtois sur une
autre bière blonde aujourd'hui et ça lui
donne un goût particulier spécifique
on espère le croire on est très heureux
de dire qu'aujourd'hui on travaille avec
de l'orge francon ton neutre est
heureuse met en avant le travail de nos
agriculteurs de la filière franc
comtoise de bière et au delà de la bière
c'est pas seulement une boisson voilà il
ya des acteurs derrière ces les
agriculteurs les brasseurs les
producteurs de houblon et c'est bon en
tout cas là aussi comme pour la saucisse
est assez validé c'est en effet très
très bon
on va peut-être aller manger après pour
aussi évacuer la bière mais c'est d'être
et vous remercier loïc
cauret que serait un repas sans un bon
dessert que serait la france sans du
fromage alors je m'y connais pas
beaucoup en spécialité bourguignonne les
franc comtoises je me connais encore
moins en fromage suit avec daniel il va
m'expliquer déjà là sur ce plateau on a
quoi alors on a un ego ce
fromage affiné on a un autre c'est
pareil c'est un fromage à ces efforts
ona brillat savarin qui a filé mais qui
lui est un fromage aussi d'où
là
chaource c'est quoi leur particularité à
ses fromages ils ont fait comme le vin
ils ont un
un terroir ils ont une manière de les
conserver les préparer d affiner c'est
comme le comté comme tous ces fromages
là qui sont préparées par les les
agriculteurs et puis les fromages et
qu'il laisse en occupe vous en avez un
préférez vous comment est ce que vous en
avez à peu près aucun a compté 1 et moi
j'aime bien bria j'aime bien
chez les brochets j'aime beaucoup je
veux bien goûter les poisses est-ce que
ça fromages forts les points
j'aime pas trop les fromages forts mais
je veux bien tester pour ce soir est ce
qu'on peut avoir un petit bout du coup
ça se mange avec quoi ça peut se manger
avec quoi les poisses voit les pointes
vous pouvez manger ça avec un lot enfin
le déguster avec un vin blanc ou un vin
rouge aussi mais avec un vin du jura ça
va très bien bon alors même 120 moi qui
n'aime pas vraiment le fou mal ça très
sympa très bon bon on aurait aimé goûter
plein d'autres choses est du vin de
bourgogne des escargots de la volaille
de bresse monde encore un petit peu de
temps avant de manger tout ça puisqu'on
reste jusqu'à samedi au salon de
l'agriculture
vous pouvez retrouver tous nos
reportages tous nos articles sur france
3 bourgogne franche comté et sur nos
sites et nos réseaux sociaux